the movie opens up with a couple college
students james and petra enjoying
quality time together due to
oversleeping the next day james arrives
late at his philosophy class just when
his teacher zimit is about to close the
door however being the last day of their
class zimit allows him in and starts
discussing the thought exercises that he
had taught them to survive in the modern
world one by one the students recall the
challenging exercises which they learnt
throughout the year one of the exercises
includes the theory that if a monkey is
given a typewriter and enough time to
type a book one day he will definitely
type the whole book but if that monkey's
name is george r.r martin those books
are never coming out following this
zemit informs them that before they
depart they will indulge themselves in
one last thought exercise in this
exercise the students have to organize
their thought process when the whole is
suffering from an atomic cataclysm in a
flash the scene changes to their
experimental place where atomic bombs
are being detonated in the distance soon
zimit takes them to a bunker and informs
them that it can only accommodate 10
people for the year james suggests they
all stay in the bunker but zimit tells
him that the radiation outside will take
at least one year to return to normal
limits and the oxygen inside the bunker
cannot hold more than 10 people back in
the class petra thinks that it is cruel
to select 10 out of 21 candidates and
leave the others to die in radiation
hence she decides to opt out of the
experiment and prepares to leave
surprisingly zimit stops her and
threatens to lower james's academic
grade if she leaves hearing this petra
is compelled to stay for the thought
exercise after this zemit asks the
students to choose from a list of cards
in which their probable profession is
written based on which the students will
select the worthy candidates to enter
the bunker for some reason zimit coughs
badly when petra and james select their
cards from the box as soon as the
distribution of the cards is completed
zimit inquires with the students about
their professions james is a farmer
while petra is an engineer for the
experiment the scene again shifts back
to their experimental site where zimit
shoots one of the students when he
discloses his profession as a poet
there's a time and a place for poetry
says zameet and this ain't it taken
aback petra questions him for doing this
but zumit defends himself by saying that
a poet is of no use inside the bunker
and that he also saved him from being
scorched by the nuclear radiation zimit
is also part of the experiment but his
ability is hidden from the group and it
is up to them to decide if they want to
let him enter the bunker one by one the
students start mentioning their worth
for being in the bunker and how they can
help others in need followed by the
voting to decide their fate while
selecting the last individual for the
bunker the group has to select between
an opera singer and a zemede realizing
that zamit has some unrevealed ability
and that opera singing is the most
annoying sound on earth the group
decides to choose him over the singer
after the selection of the worthy
candidates the selected group takes five
minutes to greet their other classmates
moments later when the selected
candidates are sitting around talking
they hear gunshots
they run to the spot and are shocked to
see that zamit has killed all of the
abandoned students in particular petra
is devastated and she tells james that
she does not want zimid inside the
bunker following this james devises a
plan and informs everyone to gather
inside the bunker except zameed when
everyone starts running towards the
bunker zameet also tries to follow them
however before he can enter the group
closes the door inside the bunker
everyone starts exploring the facilities
trying to find anything interesting
later at night when petra goes to take a
look at zameet she finds him in a very
miserable condition because of the
atomic radiation present outside before
he collapses outside the door zamit
shows a paper to petra which mentions
that only he knows the exit code of the
bunker soon the entire group arrives but
they assume that zimit was only trying
to make them feel bad for leaving him
outside however as they cannot open the
door in the present the group decides to
endure the year and face whatever will
happen afterwards with this the students
start passing their days using the help
of just about anything that they can get
their hands on meanwhile petra regularly
visits zimit's corpse outside the bunker
and feels sad for whatever they did to
him the time inside the bunker is not
easy or fun for the group rather it is
agonizing and frustrating as they are
not allowed to go outside and play in
the next scene a year has passed inside
the bunker and the students prepare to
leave unfortunately they find that they
need to enter a passcode to exit the
bunker and that zamit was actually
telling the truth the group tries their
best to break the glass of the bunker
but fails in every attempt eventually
all of them die as the oxygen inside the
bunker runs out the scene then shifts
back to the classroom where zimit tells
the students that they should have
thought logically before locking him
outside the bunker he also reveals that
his real profession was the bunker
builder and because of this he was the
only one who knew the code to open the
bunker today's lesson class is to always
trust sus strangers following this he
again makes the group take part in the
next thought exercise the students are
hesitant but for the sake of their
grades they reluctantly agree next the
group is taken to a location where
volcanoes are erupting everywhere zameed
asks the students to look at their cards
for information after reading the
students find their professions james is
still an organic farmer but is now gay
what while petra is an electrical
engineer both of them are selected as
worthy candidates to be in the bunker
and a few of the previous candidates are
exchanged this time zumit gets a spot
because only he knows the code to open
the bunker door after a while the
selected ones rush towards the bunker
while the abandoned ones rush to get a
car and leave the place unfortunately
when they try to drive away a huge
volcanic avalanche engulfs them later at
night when petra goes to meet james she
is shocked to see him getting intimate
with one of the boys devastated she
walks out of the room and sits on a
couch after some time everyone is
discussing how they can procreate and
increase the human population each of
them starts to choose their partner and
goes to their room sadly james cannot
accompany petra as he is gay because of
this petra decides to select zimit as
her partner instead she grabs his hand
and takes him to the other room 10 weeks
pass by but still there are no signs of
pregnancy within the bunker zumit then
suggests that they should change their
partners and try again someone needs to
cancel this teacher immediately however
one of the students bonnie refuses his
suggestion and states that he is always
wrong hearing this zumit gets angry and
leaves the room after a while he returns
with a gun and points it at bonnie he
then orders everyone to go out of the
room except bonnie despite zimit's
orders jack who likes bonnie hides
behind the door and when zimit is about
to shoot her he attacks him from the
back the two fight and jack somehow
manages to stab zamit with a pencil
because of the injury zameet becomes
desperate for revenge he immediately
heads out and opens the entrance door of
the bunker sadly the volcanic fire
enters the place and kills everyone
within seconds back in the classroom
james asks zameet why he coughed earlier
when he was distributing the cards to
him in petra zameet replies that he has
a cold but james is suspicious about it
mentioning that he does not care about
his grades james pretends to leave the
classroom but just then he grabs
zameet's box and rushes outside on
opening the box james learns that zamit
has been tricking him and petra by
tampering with their cards every single
time he returns to the classroom and
confronts zimit for his act calling it
cheating however zimit defends himself
by saying that he was trying to prepare
james for the real world scenario
bringing him out of his privileged life
james still does not believe his teacher
so he suggests that they go through the
third round of the thought exercise the
whole class also agrees and zamit is
forced to comply in the following scene
the group again arrives on an imaginary
island that is going to be attacked with
nuclear bombs as soon as they reach
there zumit goes to the bunker to do a
quick inspection of the place inside he
grabs a gun for himself and hides the
rest he hears a voice inside the bunker
but does not pay much attention to it
once outside petra goes to zimit and
gives him a warm hug mentioning that all
of them have been hard on him peter then
approaches the group and asks them to
trust her as she is going to select the
candidates this time everyone agrees and
the selection begins surprisingly petra
goes against zameet's suggestions and
starts choosing individuals who might
pose a risk or lack technical expertise
such as an opera singer and a poet petra
excludes herself and selects james to
fill the last spot for the bunker zimit
mentions that they will not remain alive
as the group she selected has no
expertise to prepare anything however
petra defends herself by saying that the
group can at least enjoy their time
while inside those artists are bound to
make some babies enraged with her choice
for not including him zameet reaches for
his bag for his gun but is surprised to
not find it there petra then comes
forward and tells zemit that she took
out the gun while they were talking to
each other some time before zameet takes
the gun from her and points it at james
to shoot him but james is already
holding a rifle which zamit hid while he
was inspecting the place the sound that
zameet heard while he was hiding the gun
was james who was keeping an eye on him
zamit then reminds them that they will
require the code to exit the bunker and
he is the only one who knows it to his
surprise bonnie who also has an
excellent iq recites the code for him it
turns out that she had seen zemit using
the code during the second experiment
having no other choice zimit walks away
a while later when petra and the other
unselected classmates also prepare to
leave she realizes that they do not have
the key to the boat just then chip one
of the bunker candidates tells petra
that he has the keys when she goes to
retrieve them chip cleverly pulls petra
inside the bunker steps out and closes
the door after this he runs towards the
boat with his other friends and tries to
reach the nearby island before the
nuclear bombs are dropped inside the
bunker the group enjoys their time by
painting singing and doing all the
things they like james expresses his
love for petra but for some reason she
cannot return the sentiment after
spending a whole year of fun and
creativity the group steps out of the
bunker and is shocked to find the island
still in its original state without any
nuclear attack despite zimit's narration
that they would all perish since none of
them have the technological abilities to
survive they have come this far however
since all their supplies have run out
they don't have much time to live
moments later a nuclear warhead lands on
the beach as the group has already
enjoyed a full year they're ready to
embrace death james makes his way to
detonate the warhead but just then a
barbaric-looking zemit arrives with his
gun and tells james to step away it
turns out that he lived in a nearby cave
for the entire year he threatens to
shoot james and kill him but
surprisingly the other survivors stand
in front of james after this the group
detonates the warhead together and
everyone is killed the scene shifts back
to the class where zimit mentions that
the most recent exercise was unpleasant
everyone departs when the lesson is over
but petra stays behind and accuses the
meat of trying to punish her and james
with the exercise james in zimit's
opinion does not deserve petra here it
is revealed that zimit has been having
an affair with petra and during the
whole exercise he was just trying to
punish james petra tells zameet that
intelligence isn't the only factor to
consider when it comes to survival and
satisfaction she then tells him that she
loves james and leaves the classroom the
movie ends with dimit sitting by himself
in the classroom contemplating different
thought exercises like before eventually
he reaches into his drawer for a
revolver and a gunshot can be heard
whoever wrote this movie has some issues
that they need to sort out subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching